Hey there strange lovers, Julian here for
DNews.
Welcome to the Sanctum Sanctorum, the home
of Earth’s Sorcerer Supreme!
It's from the upcoming Dr. Strange movie!
And in the movie, Dr. Strange defends our
world from invaders from other dimensions,
using his mind and mystic artifacts of untold
power.
And I know it sounds strange, but some physicists
think the idea that there are multiple universes
other than our own is entirely possible, and
what it means is that out there could be people
like-
Hello Julian
Well, like him.
Yeah, I was afraid of that, he’s evil.
See our universe is big, really big, possibly
even infinite.
But since there's only 118 elements, you can
only combine them in so many ways.
That means, eventually everything is going
to have an exact copy.
And that means there should also be copies
of us that are just a little bit... off.
There could be a version of me that’s left
handed or has perfect eyesight or has crazy
opinions.
Comb your hair!
Now under normal circumstances you should
have to travel really, really far away to
run into these exact copies.
MIT Cosmologist Max Tegmark thinks you should
have to travel 10 to the 10 to the 29 meters
before running into that handsome devil.
That’s a number so huge it needed a second
level of exponents to convey: it’s exponentially
exponential!
So how Evil Julian got here I don't know,
maybe through an Einstein-Rosen bridge DON'T
TOUCH THAT!
Well that’s just great, now we have another
universe to deal with.
And ut looks like reverse Julian over here,
or Nailuj as I call him, is from another theorized
kind of universe.
But unlike Evil Julian’s, is entirely separate
from our own.
Nailuj seems to be from a universe where the
"arrow of time" flows backwards.
In our universe, it flows forwards because
things move from a state of order to chaos:
balloons pop, candles go out, and we age and
get more wrinkly.
But some theorize that on the other side of
the Big Bang could be a mirror universe, where
the arrow of time, at least from our perspective
points backwards!
So balloons un-pop, candles un-blow, and Nailij
just keeps getting younger and smoother.
Of course, on this side of the Big Bang, it
is possible that there are other universes
making up a multiverse.
One popular idea almost immediately after
the Big Bang space expanded at a rate so rapidly,
multiple times the speed of light, that eventually
it slowed down and the universe we saw coalesced.
But opens up the possibility that some areas
didn't stop expanding and until later.
They kept inflating like bubbles.
And eventually when they slowed down and their
universes formed, they were completely different
from our own.
In these universes the laws of physics can
be totally different.
Electrons and protons could have different
masses or gravity could have different strengths.
The speed of light itself could even different!
So what that means is in these universes,
the constants we know and love, could mean
that atoms can't form and nothing can exist.
And it looks like this particular universe
is not contained inside it's bubble.
Oh man, Trace and the DNews gang are going
to kill me.
If this torrential void doesn’t destroy
the entire universe first.
Um, I have an idea...
Well that was convenient.
Of course all these ideas are just possible
ways that other universes could exist.
But that means that there are some very tantalizing
possibilities out there.
What if somewhere out there, superheroes are
real.
And they're not just the product of so guy
named Stan's imagination.
If the universe like the really existed, well
that would really be a Marvel.
Hey we'd like to thank Disney, Marvel and
Youtube for coming together to make this whole
crazy thing happen.
If you guys like what you saw, go ahead and
subscribe and we'll see you next time on DNews.